الى اخر تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث قال حكيم مقاطعه الروسيه ان اربعه
اشخاص اصيبوا في قصف اوكراني على مدينه
شيش بنكو في المقاطعه واضاف ان القصف ادى
الى اضرار بمنازل وسيارات عده واحراق متجر
وعلى الحاكم عن عمليات لنحو ثلاثمائه
منطق او اجلاء حوالي ثلاثمائم من منطقتين
شيش بنكو
وارسالهم الى مناطق اخرى
كما اعلنت سلطاته الطوارئ في اقليم
كرسنودار الروسيه عن سقوط مسيره اوكرانيا
صباح اليوم في منشاه لتكرير النفط غرب
مدينه كريسندار دون ان تلحق خسائر او
اضرار بها وكان حاكم اقليم كرسم دار
الروسي قال ان حريق النشب في مصفاه
افيبسكي لتكرير النفط في الاقليم نتيجته
هجوم دون سياره اوكرانيه وافاد الحاكم عبر
تيليجرام انه قد تمت السيطره على الحريق
واخماده بالفعل مشيرا الى انه لم تسجل اي
اصابات يشار الى ان روسيا واوكرانيا
تستخدم المسيرات في هجماتها المتبادله في
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا المستمره منذ
اكثر من 15 شهرا
معنى من دون يسق مراسله الجزيره كارمن
جوغدار نجم المعكي كل هذه التطورات
المدنيه
نعم مياده اسمحيلي قبل الحديث عن هذه
التفاصيل هناك خبر وصلنا من دقائق هو صادر
عن موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي يقول ان
القوات الروسيه استهدفت
بضربه صاروخيه استهدفت واغرقت سفينه
الانزال الاوكرانيه يوري اوليفيرينكو اذا
هذا الخبر وردنا قبل ثوان بالاحرى عن
اغراق واستهداف هذه السفينه الاوكرانيه في
منطقه اوديسكا بالتحديد عند البحر الاسود
يجب ان ننتظر لمعرفه تفاصيل هذا الاستهداف
ولكن في اخر التفاصيل هناك مستويات عده
لهذه المعركه تتخذ مناح مختلفه اولا
الاستهداف المستمر لمقاطعه بيل جرود ما
دفع السلطات المحليه هناك لنقل المدنيين
وبدء بنقل المدنيين الى مناطق اكثر امانا
اذ ان بعض القرى والمدن في لم تعد امنه
ايضا هذا يمكن ربطه بما يجري فكره التي
تعرضت منشاتين نفطيتين فيها
لاستهداف اوكراني بمسيارتين هذا الاستهداف
ليس الاول وتكرر كثيرا في مقاطعه في اقليم
كرسنادار الذي يقع جنوبه جنوب روسيا وهو
له اهميه بالغه لناحيه وصل هذه الجزء هذا
الجزء من روسيا بشبه جزيره القرم التي
كانت ضمتها روسيا اليها هذا الامر ايضا
يمكن ربطه بالاستهدافات الاوكرانيه التي
تكثفت في الفتره الماضيه على الاراضي
الروسيه كنا تحدثنا عن بيسكوف هذه هناك
جرى استهداف منشاه نفطيه وايضا يوم امس
الاستهداف الكبير الذي تعرضت له موسكو
العاصمه كل هذه الاسئله الاستهدافات يقرا
فيها المحللون محاوله لنقل جزء من الصراع
الى الاراضي الروسيه وبطبيعه الحال هذا
سيكون له في المرحله المقبله وقد يبدل في
المعطيات الميداليه مياده ايضا تطور فيما
خس جبهه هذه المقاطعه التي تشهد فيها عدد
من الجبهات معارك محتدمه الخرائط العسكريه
تظهر تقدما للقوات الروسيه في محور ابيافك
بالتحديد وقبل قليل كان هناك تصريح لرمضان
قديروف الرئيس الشيشاني الذي كشف عن خطط
مستقبليه لقواته للانتشار في عدد من المدن
في وقال انه بالفعل القوات الشيشانيه
المقاتله على عدد من الجبهات فيزا في
دانياس ايضا هي في قد تلقت اوامر بالهجوم
من دونيسك مراسله الجزيره كارمن شكرا
جزيلا لك